22 year old woman is to be sentenced for
perverting the court of justice after
making false rape allegations which
rocked her hometown of Barrow and
furnace in Cumbria Eleanor Williams
alleged she had been the victim of an
Asian grooming gang in a post on
Facebook in May 2020 allegations which
led to three men trying to take their
own lives a warning we're now going to
go to the live feed of the sentencing
and due to the nature of this case there
could be language used that some
this is
and because of hundreds of pages of
evidence that has been served
specifically for sentencing hearing
I've also heard evidence during the
course of the sentence hearing
this is not a case where it's necessary
for me to obtain a pre-sentence report
this will inevitably be a lengthy prison
sentence and I have a great deal of
information about this defendant's
situation from her evidence in the case
and the many psychiatric reports
by way of very broad summary this
defendant made serious allegations of a
sexual nature against a large number of
men between the October of 2017 and
March 2020
in relation to each of the counts there
are a number of ways in which the jury
could have convicted the defendant
each count was divided into paragraphs A
and B
paragraph a in each count represented
the making of false allegations
paragraph B in each count represented
the fabrication of evidence to support
those those allegations
in all counts apart from Counts six and
nine
paragraph a was further particularized
the jury was directed that they should
only convict if the crown had proved so
that they were all sure of at least one
of paragraph a or one of its particulars
or of paragraph B
thus it is important for me to identify
in each count my findings as to what was
proved to the criminal standard
at the time of the commission of count
one the defendant was 16 and 17. in
relation to counts two to four she was
18. in relation to the other counts she
was either 18 or 18 and 19. she's now 22
having turned 22 during the course of
her trial
on count one the defendant made an
allegation against a young man whom I
will refer to as C who was hosting an
informal getch together at his house the
defendant became drunk and smoked
cannabis such that she was sick
and others called for the defendant's
sister and mother and her mother picked
her up
she then alleged to the hospital that
she had been raped and made a police
videotaped interview in which she
asserted that seed had kissed her
watched her urinate commented on her
pubic area touched her bottom sat on top
of her exposed her breasts and kissed
them
he had she said threatened to set his
dog on her and bury her in the garden or
take her and put her in the sea
I am sure that this entire account is
false and that she knew it was false
it was the Crown's case that she then
created messages to herself which
strengthened her allegation against C
whilst I'm sure that these messages were
not genuinely from C or from anyone
present that night I am not sure that
these messages were fabricated by the
defendant
it remains in my judgment of possibility
that these messages were created by
ill-intentioned Third parties
it follows that in relation to count one
she will be sentenced on the basis that
she is guilty under paragraph a but not
under paragraph B
as a result of this allegation C was
arrested and interviewed on the 27th of
November 2017.
he wasn't remanded into custody but had
the matter hanging over him until the
march of 2018 the defendant had
withdrawn her support for the
prosecution in the January of 2018.
in relation to counts two three and four
the defendant made three separate
allegations of rape against one Jordan
trengov who is content to be named in
these remarks
she went on a night out on the 8th of
March 2019 into the 9th of March 2019
with Mr trengov and others she drank or
took drugs such that she became
intoxicated and had to be taken home
over the next few days she began to hear
others talking on social media about
what had happened on that night out
I'm perfectly satisfied that there was
no basis for her believing that she had
been sexually assaulted that night
however she chose to assert that she'd
been taken to an address by Mr trengo
raped and then taken back into Barrow in
furnace
in order to support the allegation she
created a number of false messages of
which she took screenshots purporting to
be from Mr trengov in which he support
made supposed admissions in the most
derogatory terms
she sent those messages to herself and
then took screenshots of them so that
they could be handed to the police
she made the first of a number of errors
in that one of the accounts she used to
send these messages was created from her
family home using the IP address of the
Wi-Fi network there
after creating these messages she then
on the 6th of May 2019 called the police
from her flat alleging that she'd been
attacked that day
At first she feigned reluctance to give
an account but eventually made a false
allegation about the 8th and the 9th of
March 2019 and the 6th of May 2019. in
relation to the 6th of May she alleged
that Mr trengo had come to her flat
she'd let him in and he wouldn't leave
she said he tried she tried to push him
out and they started to fight
he had a lock knife with which he
threatened her she said that he stripped
her naked in the living room and pulled
her into the bathroom by her hair
she alleged that he then beat her with a
shower head she said that he raped her
and didn't use a condom at one point
when they were on the floor he
threatened to kill her and said he would
enjoy raping her
she said she had bruises to her legs she
was indeed injured but this account was
a complete fabrication Mr trengov was
not even there she knew it was false
she did indeed have injuries but she'd
calls them to herself to support her
allegation
and as we will see this was to become a
feature of her conduct
Mr trengov was then arrested and
interviewed about both incidents and was
at that time bailed
then on the 18th of May 2019 she game
called the police claiming that Mr
trango had again come to her flat and
violently raped her
she alleged that she'd come home from a
night out Mr trengov arrived at her
house and came in through the door which
was not locked as she was expecting a
friend
she tried to push him out and they
fought
she said that he struck her on her face
and her body
as she was on the floor She alleged that
he raped her
he wore a condom
the police as she phoned the police who
appeared to have found her
unconscious and naked on the floor
again she was injured again these were
self-inflicted again this was a false
allegation which she knew to be false
again Mr trengov was never even there
this time Mr trengo was arrested but not
bailed he remained in custody until the
1st of August 2019.
he was told that matters would not be
pursued on the 20th of August 2019.
in relation to counts two three and four
which concern Mr trengov unsatisfied so
that I am sure that the messages which
she provided to the police apparently
from Mr trengov were created by the
defendant in order to support her false
allegations
it follows that in respect of these
counts she will be sentenced on the
basis of both paragraphs A and B
I will now summarize the evidence on
count 5.
on the 18th of June 2019 the defendant
made allegation to detective inspector
Nutter that she had been the victim of
sex traffickers who had since she was 12
or 13 sold her for sex at so-called sex
parties
her account mainly centered around a
local businessman Muhammad ramzan who
was also content to be named in these
remarks
she said that he had befriended her when
she was 12 and shortly thereafter had
sex with her and then done so regularly
she said that Mr ramzan then persuaded
her to have sex with another man
this turned into her being taken across
the region to have sex with men
she described the abuse in some detail
she and other girls were abused she
claimed that the sexual acts would be
filmed and those films sold she spoke
about individual acts of abuse a girl
who'd had a knife inserted into her
vagina and was then forced to have sex
before it was healed
she spoke of punishment beatings meted
after girls who didn't do as they were
told now due to the explicit nature of
the upcoming remarks in this case We've
Come away for a short while a reminder
that being sentenced as 22 year old
Eleanor Williams who had claimed to have
been groomed trafficked raped and beaten
by Asian gangs in Cumbria in 2020 she
was found guilty of perverting the
course of Justice earlier this year and
we will return to those proceedings at
Preston Crown Court just shortly where
judge Robert Altman is uh reviewing the
key factors in the case before
delivering the sentence let's go back in
now
supplied a long list of men who were
traffickers they were not
she said she'd been taken to Amsterdam
by Mr ramzan and forced to work in a
brothel
she also said that on that same trip she
had been sold by Mr ramzan for 25
000 Euros but the buyer did not go
through with the deal
she said that on another occasion an
attempt had been made to take out of
Pakistan
on another that she had been housed in a
caravan for two weeks in the United
Kingdom
there she had been subdued by being
forcibly injected with Heroin so that A
procession of men could have sex with
her for money
she said that there were constant
parties in which she and other young
females were forced to attend often
given detailed instructions as to what
to wear
she was made to take a young girl for an
illegal abortion
all of this was complete fabrication she
created an extensive cast of traffickers
many with detailed biographers some were
invented altogether others existed but
were not traffickers at all
she also made allegations about being
taken for sexual exploitation to ibizler
for two weeks where men paid Mr ramzan
to have sex with her
this allegation was also shown to be
false indeed in police interview when
confronted with the possibility of
travel records being checked she
admitted that this account was False
only to seek to replace it with another
lie subsequently at trial
detective inspector Nutter was
understandably troubled by what she
heard
she spent a good deal of time with the
defendant believing that she was the
victim of serious exploitation and that
there was a highly dangerous ring of
traffickers operating in the Barrow in
furnace area
she arranged a meeting of regional
police forces to begin a major
multi-force investigation
she offered the defendant a safe house
or even participation in a witness
protection scheme
the crown were able to prove and I am
sure that the allegations were a
complete fiction
certain parts were readily disprovable
she had been to Amsterdam but with her
sister and her sister's partner to save
money they had all three shared a hotel
room at night and were in each other's
company all day
at trial the defendant tried to claim
that the attempt to sell her by Mr
ramzan happened on this trip but her
sister and her sister's partner gave
evidence to the effect that she was
never out of their sight
the females she named as co-victims of
trafficking was spoken to
many were profoundly upset by the
suggestion
Some Gave evidence at court but many of
the statements denying they'd ever been
trafficked were agreed and read at trial
none of them had been trafficked
during the investigation Mr ramzan was
arrested
he'd never really met the defendant had
nothing whatsoever to do with
trafficking had never been alone in a
room with her let alone had sex with her
he described in court his utter
consternation of being publicly arrested
on the Promenade in Walnut Island and
questioned by the police
I'll set out more of the impact of this
offending upon him and his family later
in these remarks
the defendant set about seeking to back
up her allegations against Mr ramzan and
the fictitious traffickers she did so in
a number of ways I will summarize here
only some of them
she manipulated people with whom she was
in contact via Snapchat to contact her
she would rename these people in her
phone with the names of supposed
traffickers
she would induce sexual messages from
them and take a screenshot of those
messages
thus it would appear that she had a
message with a sexual overtone from
someone with the name of one of the
supposed traffickers
when she was in the police station she
would elicit such messages to ensure
that there was live evidence of the
supposed traffickers pestering her
a number of these people came to court
to give evidence
one young man from Essex had been
rebadged by the defendant in her phone
as Shaggy the name of one of the
supposed people traffickers from Barrow
he was in fact a young man from Essex
who'd had little contact with the
defendant she told him she was from
Portsmouth and cultivated a friendship
with him to create messages she could
later use
another was a vague School acquaintance
who wanted a relationship with her he
was renamed to Harem or rammy
she then took screenshots of these
messages falsely appearing to come from
Harry Harem or rammy so that she could
say there were evidence of her being
trafficked
the defendant manipulated friends and
work colleagues to involve them
unwittingly in her deceptions
she invented people in her phone who
simply didn't exist
she sometimes used two phones one to
send and want to receive messages from
supposed traffickers or traffic women
she would then take screenshots of those
messages
there were other types of message she
created she would inflict unpleasant
injuries on herself which she later
attributed to fictitious traffickers
she wrote letters to herself supposedly
from Remy she made false diary entries
based upon the evidence I have heard I'm
sure of all of the matters which I've
set out above it follows that in
relation to count five she has to be
sentenced on the basis of all of the
particulars under paragraph a and
paragraph B
I turned to count six
whilst the defendant had refused to
participate in a witness protection
program she did agree to be temporarily
housed by the police in a hotel close to
Kendall police station
the police arranged for her to have a
job there
these events happen during the time
frame of count five however because the
issue was completely different to the
remainder of Camp 5 it was reflected in
a separate count it's convenient to deal
with it at this stage
on the 30th of June 2019 the defendant
left the hotel provided by the police
and traveled to Blackpool by train
she'd already booked herself a hotel
room there
the Undisputed evidence was that she
checked into her room and spent most of
her time there
when she did go out she was alone and on
foot
she was seen on video to make a note of
her on her phone of the vehicle
registration number of a car and the
details of a takeaway restaurant
having done so she went to a shop bought
some food sat in her hotel room and
watched YouTube videos
the next day she got up late and made
her way to Preston
the police in her family were worried
about her she had ignored their messages
eventually police officers traced her to
Preston and met her there
she was driven home to Barrow in furnace
and in the early hours of the morning
detective inspector Nutter came to meet
her worried as to what had happened
the defender was later to tell the
police in great detail but the traffic
the traffickers had found her in Kendall
and instructed her to go to Blackpool
there she said she was met by Mr ramzan
and threatened with a violent death
she was made to visit four premises and
at each she was brutally raped by
multiple men
the car whose registration number she
had noted down was she said used to
transport her between properties
a flat above the takeaway whose details
she had noted down was for the venue for
one of these attacks
officers took her to Blackpool twice to
try and identify the locations of these
places
this account was all completely false
eventually confronted by
incontrovertible evidence she was forced
to accept that none of this was true
she was later to claim at trial that she
was forced to give this false account by
the traffickers but I Ruled that duress
was not available to her
indeed I am sure that no one pressured
her to go to Blackpool at all she did so
entirely of her own volition in order to
make up false allegations against Mr
ramzan and others
I turned to count seven
on the 18th of July 2019 the defendant
caught a train to Leeds
the clear evidence is that she spent a
good part of the day in the park
she had two phones with her
she then traveled back to Preston where
she walked into the Town Center
a young man walking home from a family
party happened upon her he asked her for
a light and they started to talk
they had a brief and entirely consensual
sexual encounter
the defendant then caught the train to
Barrow in furnace exchanging details
with the young man and tentatively
agreeing to meet him at a later date
once in barrow-in furnace she walked to
her flat her brother's girlfriend
happened to see her as she walked her
home picked her up and took her home
much of this including much of what
happened in Preston was caught on closed
circuit television
by now it was the early hours of the
19th of July
once her brother learned from his
girlfriend that the defendant was at
home he called the police
everyone had been frantically worried
about her all day and she had been
ignoring their messages
when the police arrived at her house the
defendant pretended to be semi-conscious
the jury and I saw body warm footage
captured by the officers it's clear that
the defendant was play acting pretending
to be semi-conscious
she was injured but the clear evidence
was that she had inflicted the injuries
upon herself
she then created a false account of what
had happened in Leeds Preston and Barrow
that day
all of this account was inconsistent
with CCTV telephone and other evidence
she told the police that on Wednesday
the 17th of July a man called salza an
invented trafficker came to her door
he'd stacked her in the face pinned her
to the wall by the neck he told her to
follow orders she would get on Snapchat
said that she had lost the money and she
needed to earn them ten thousand pounds
as a result
she said that she was then told to go to
Leeds
there she was taken to a house where she
had sex with two men
she and a girl called Molly then walked
to another premises
there were other girls there
there she said she had sex with three
men
she was then driven to a chicken shop
and headingley where she had sex with
another man
she sent then said she was driven to
Bramley and then to Bradford where she
had sex with three men
she then saw her passport on the table
with a ring on it and flight details to
Bangladesh so she ran
when the traffickers were able to
contact her by phone she was told to go
to Preston
she said that the young man she had met
in Preston was a trafficker and that he
had sent her a message telling her that
he had lined up some cocaine on a bench
and she had no choice but to take it
she said that he took her to two Asian
men who paid him to have sex with her
she then said that the young man himself
then took her down a back alley and
raped her
eventually she said she was allowed to
return to Barrow in furnace
salza met her at the train station and
he drove her home
we have seen the video footage of her
walking home
she said that when she opened her door
he and another man forced their way in
and she was forced to have sex with them
both
salza struck her in the face and toilet
had sought herself out and that they
will be back for her at 2 am
10 minutes later the police arrived and
she could not recall anything further
until she woke in hospital
this was a complete fabrication
much of it could be disproved from CCTV
in Preston and Barrow in furnace what
happened in Leeds was shown to be false
by the location of her phone
she had during the course of the Day
created other evidence to support the
false account she knew she would give
most notably she had used one of the two
phones she had with her that day to send
messages from a person she described as
Nicole to herself
she'd then taken screenshots of those
messages
Nicole was supposed to be a fellow
trafficked woman who was being raped at
the parties
Nicole was supposedly angry at the
defendant for leaving her and the other
victims in Leeds
however the agreed evidence was that
when Nicole was apparently complaining
about being left in Leeds by the
defendant the phone from which the
messages were being sent was with the
defendant on the train back to Preston
she was sending the Nicole messages from
one phone in her possession to the other
phone in her possession
I turned now to count eight
in May 2020 the defendant was on bail
for perverting the course of Justice
it's clear that she was still intent on
trying to invent evidence to support her
previous accounts
in the earlier part of 2020 the
instances of her apparently going
missing and turning up intoxicated and
injured and increased
on the 18th of May 2020 she set out from
home on foot
it's clear from the evidence that she
never left war on the island and never
entered a vehicle
2249 she was found by police in fields
close to her home
she had multiple injuries
one eye was swollen shut she had a
hammer injuries to her legs and abdomen
which were too numerous to count
part of her little finger was partly
severed
these injuries were all self-inflicted
her account was that she had intended to
catch a bus to travel to Barrow but one
of the males associated with those who'd
exploited her offered her a lift which
she accepted
she then said that she was taken to a
house in Barrow and furnace
there were 10 males there she said that
a number of named men raped her at that
property
one of them assaulted her and tried to
cut her finger off one of them drove her
back to wall the island she walked off
to where the police found her
a few days later
the police found a hammer which she had
purchased some days before it was hidden
against the fence close to where the
police had found her it bore traces of
her blood and DNA
a home office a home office pathologist
gave evidence to the effect that the
serious injuries she had sustained were
completely inconsistent with her account
and completely consistent with being
self-inflicted with the hammer which she
had bought which was found close to her
and which bore her DNA
on the 20th of May 2019 the defendant
made a Facebook post in which she posted
shocking photographs of the injuries she
had inflicted upon herself
these photographs were very graphic and
bound to produce a significant response
in that post she referred to these
having been inflicted by three as she
put it Asian men as they took her to
various sex parties in that same post
she referred to having been similarly
abused by Asian men and men of Pakistani
origin in various locations across the
north of England for a number of years
she said that she would continue to tell
the police everything she knew she
encouraged parents to be vigilant and
children to speak out if they were
concerned
she did not mention that she was already
on bail for perverting the course of
Justice
I turned to count nine to which the
defendant pleaded guilty
this admission represents her writing a
letter from custody to her sister asking
her sister to tell her that is the
defendant's solicitors that a hammer had
been found in her bedroom
this was an attempt to create a false
defense to count eight
when she entered her plea it was on the
basis only of what she wrote to her
sister and not what was said to her
mother in the context of this case it is
not necessary to decide that issue and I
will sentence her on her basis
the defendant is 22.
she had no convictions prior to these
matters coming before the court
I note that she was under 18 at the time
of the commission of count one
she had turned 18 by the time all other
offenses were committed but I bear in
mind her young age and the principles
set out in the guideline in relation to
sentencing children and young people
though she was an adult at the time of
the commission of the vast majority of
this offending I must bear in mind her
maturity as well as her chronological
age
there is evidence that she is immature
apart from her age there is some other
personal mitigation
there are clear overtones of
difficulties in her childhood she's been
self-harming from a young age however
there is little clarity about what these
difficulties involved it is mitigation
that before this offending she was of
good character
it is troubling to say the least that
she shows no significant sign of remorse
even continuing to profess the truth of
her allegations
the only flicker of appreciation of what
she has done came today with a brief
note read by Her counsel regretting the
effects of her post on the 20th of May
2020.
I've received much psychiatric evidence
in this case all of which I've read I
heard evidence yesterday from Dr bacon
called on behalf of the defendant
Dr bacon maintains that the defendant
has a complex post-traumatic stress
disorder
Dr Locke who has provided a report for
the crown does not accept that this is a
condition a conclusion which can be
drawn given that there is no
satisfactory account of any antecedent
trauma
I agree with the conclusion of Dr Locke
that there is no evidence upon which I
could conclude that there is a complex
post-traumatic stress disorder
since she has been found guilty the
defendant has hinted at other sources of
trauma but has given no real indication
as to what it could be
of course I've considered whether the
aberrant nature of these offenses means
that I should assume that the defendant
is suffering from some mental impairment
there is no explanation for why the
defendant would commit these offenses
she has gone to extraordinary lengths to
create false accusations including
causing ourselves significant injury
no explanation for this behavior is
apparent
however that does not mean that I should
speculate unless and until the defendant
chooses to say why she has told these
lies we will not know
in any event I question the relevance of
the defendant suffering from a complex
post-traumatic stress disorder in
relation to sentence
when Dr bacon gave evidence yesterday I
asked her to comment on whether such a
condition could reduce the culpability
of a person to be sentenced for
perverting the course of Justice
Dr bacon had told us that this was not
within the scope of her instruction from
the defense
when I asked the question of Dr bacon
Miss Blackwell Casey intervened telling
me he was not the defense case that the
defendant's complex post-traumatic
distress disorder if that is what she
has is relevant to culpability
I do accept that it is part of her
personal mitigation that she has
vulnerabilities that I will take into
account
I turned to the structure of the
sentence
count which concerns C and the counts
which concern Mr trenko are separate
from each other and from the other
offending in this case however the
offending accounts five six and seven
can properly be regarded as a course of
conduct
count eight and nine are together part
of the same course of conduct and whilst
they could be seen as part of that
represented by counts five six and seven
they concern a separate incident
and were committed on bail for other
matters
I intend to impose concurrent sentences
on count five six and seven however
there will be cons a consecutive
sentence on count one there will be
additional sentences on Count 2 3 and 4
concurrent with each other but
consecutive with the other sentences
there will be further sentences on
counts eight and nine concurrent with
each other but consecutive to the other
sentences save that I will temper the
structure of these sentences to give
effect to totality
there is no guideline for this offense
and I apply the general guidelines
overarching principles
the maximum sentence is at Large
I've been provided with a number of
authorities which I've read there are no
analogous offenses for which there are
guidelines
I consider first the defendant's
culpability then the harm I consider the
purposes of sentences sentencing and
then the aggravating and mitigating
features I must then consider totality
before arriving at my final sentence
the cases to which I've been referred
provide the following factors which are
amongst those that I should bear in mind
I remind myself that because this
offense strikes at the heart of the
administration of justice it is to be
regarded as serious
deterrence is an important aim of
sentencing though I must remember that
when sentencing young people this may be
extinguished or diminished by the
principal aim of the youth justice
system is to prevent offending by young
people and I must have regard to the
welfare of the defendant
this offense is fact specific previous
cases are of little assistance
when considering culpability I must take
account of the seriousness of the
underlying offense I bear in mind the
nature of the deceptive conduct and the
time over which it continued
I consider whether the offense casts
suspicion on others whether others were
arrested
in this case I'm asked to consider
Community impact are set out in detail
my Approach in this regard
in relation to all counts I bear in mind
that these were allegations of sexual
offenses
these carry not only the risk of
prosecution but also a potentially
indelible stain on the character and
reputation of everyone accused
sexual allegations even were disproved
often leave the falsely accused person
living under a general and misplaced
suspicion
I consider culpability and harm
in count one the culpability is high the
allegation was very serious however the
defendant withdrew has support for the
prosecution of C after two months the
harm is also high in his victim personal
statement C sets out how frightening it
was to be wrongly accused and then
arrested and kept in the police station
he had to remove himself from social
media because he was wrongly accused of
being a rapist
even five years later he says he doesn't
go to Barrow Town Center because he
fears he's under suspicion
he couldn't even bring himself to pick
up his son from nursery for fear of what
people were saying
he describes the defendant's false
allegations against him as the worst
experience of his life he does not think
he will ever recover
in relation to camps two to four the
culpability is higher still the
allegations were even more serious and
there were a number of them they were
maintained over a longer period they
were bolstered by the creation of false
evidence with some degree of
sophistication
the harm is also even higher than in
count one
Mr trengo's house was spray painted with
the word rapist his mother had to leave
her house
he was remanded into custody between May
and August 2019.
even when released on bail conditions he
had to live far from home for a further
19 days
when he returned to Barrow he was abused
on the street by strangers he became
isolated he tried to take his life in
August 2020 and is still taking
antidepressant medication
he lost any sense of self-confidence he
says he can no longer work
he has a child now and Social Services
received scores of Anonymous phone calls
saying he is a rapist and not safe to be
with his child
he recently moved house and a neighbor
called him a rapist saying they didn't
want him living there
the culpability in relation to counts
five six and seven could hardly be
higher the allegations made were of the
utmost severity they were made over a
protracted period
there was considerable sophistication in
the creation of false evidence to
support them
the harm in relation to these counts is
extremely high
Mr ramzan was arrested on the 7th of
July 2019 in the public Street in the
community where he lives and then held
in custody for 36 hours
two weeks after his arrest he was in
such despair that he tried to kill
himself in front of his family in the
most graphic and upsetting way
he sustained injury in that attempt
which has left scars
though he was informed the next month
that there will be no further action by
the police that was as he puts it in his
statement only the start of the worst
period of his life
he then describes being targeted by
sections of the Barrow community
he's been unable to sleep and to this
day fears for his safety the windows of
his vehicles have been smashed and their
tires damaged he and his family have had
to endure abuse the windows of his
rental property have been put in and
then once repaired immediately put in
again
he's received countless death threats
over social media he's felt anxious
going out for the last three years
his family including his children have
been affected for a period they had to
move out of the family home
he describes a trauma being
cross-examined in court during the trial
his business businesses were ruined he
describes going from a successful
businessman to someone who has virtually
nothing
also with in consideration of harm is
the young man who happened to meet the
defendant in Preston on the 18th of July
2019 on the way back from Leeds
when he was told that he'd been accused
of raping the defendant he suffered
serious consequences
tells me in his statement that he was
studying for professional exams and
doing well at work
as a result of this allegation he was
unable to continue his studies and
hasn't worked since he tells me he
suffered a serious crisis in his mental
health
he attempted to kill himself
though the tone of his statement
suggests that this false allegation was
not the only cause of these problems it
is his belief that they significantly
contributed to them
he remained anxious about going out and
meeting people he doesn't trust people
he found the trial itself very stressful
since then he has started to feel better
I turned to the statements of those who
were wrongly identified as being the
victims of exploitation
their names may not be reported they all
refer to the surprise of being
approached by the police about matters
of which they knew nothing
one then refers to particular problems
she had as she was pregnant at the time
she was spoken to and particular
problems which followed
another speaks of her feelings having
been as she puts it exploited by this
defendant
another speaks of the disruption of
being required to give evidence at court
at a particularly inconvenient time in
our life
I now turn to the question of community
impact
under Section 63 of the sentencing act
2020 I must consider the harm which the
defendant intended and that which might
reasonably might foreseeably have been
caused
I've seen statements in relation to this
topic and viewed a compilation of
footage taken at the time
according to the statement of
superintendent Pearman the period
following the Facebook post on the 20th
of May 2020 was turbulent in Barrow
he says that Barrow had not seen such a
public display of anger for 30 years
there were public demonstrations
targeting the local paper the local
Asian community and the police
this was in the height of the first
lockdown and superintendent permanent
tells me in his statement that there was
a sense of heightened tension for about
four months
the comments attracted by the
defendant's post named local businesses
who feared they'd be subject to attack
One restaurant had its Windows smashed
police resources were diverted to
dealing with the threat
death threats were made against local
restaurant owners marches were organized
to protest about a suspected police
cover-up
the fire service installed smoke alarms
at vulnerable premises
local journalists were the subject of
credible threats
one left her home and moved out of the
area
racist anti-police graffiti was sprayed
on a wall in Barrow
threats were made on social media
against the police
a demonstration Convoy of cars drove
from Barrow to ulverston and back again
on the 25th of May
the police were under pressure from
those who believed they were complicit
in a cover-up on the one hand and those
who felt unsafe at the hands of their
parent Vigilantes on the other
individual police officers on patrol
seeking to support the community in
covid was subject to insults
Social Services were also the subject of
unwarranted insults and criticism
the local newspaper was subject to
boycotts and ultimately I'm told
collapsed for financial reasons though
there's no evidence before me upon which
I could conclude that this was a direct
result of the boycott
by mid-june there were ongoing protests
these appear to have been in response to
a person from outside Barrow who was
active in the demonstrations having been
arrested
the the issue then appeared to be more
his arrest
nonetheless there were serious
consequences and Indian restaurants
windows were smashed there were further
protests and further allegations of a
police cover-up
in the meantime there were credible
threats to police officers attempts were
made to find their home addresses online
threats were made but they will be found
and they will be harmed
I'm told that this state of arrest
continued until the August of 2019.
local people felt motivated to to donate
their money to a fund which was set up
to support this defendant this fund
quickly reached 22 000 pounds
what effect if any should this have on
the sentence of the defendant
during the course of this trial I've
heard many days of evidence from this
defendant and have read hundreds of her
social media Communications
it is not the Crown's case that when she
blamed Asian and Pakistani men for her
abuse she was racially motivated
I agree with that position and will
sentence on the basis that she was not
so motivated
I note that in this case she has made
false allegations about white men also
I'm sure she chose to lie about Asian
men because she was modeling her lies on
other cases of national prominence
she regarded the prospects of being
believed as greater if she based them on
true cases already within the public
consciousness
she was not principally motivated by a
desire to stir up public unrest
however I cannot conclude that she chose
to make her Facebook post of the 20th of
May 2020 for any other reason than that
she intended to create an impact within
the town
I accept that there was no direct
incitement to do anything but it was
entirely foreseeable that there will be
considerable Community impact upon those
of Asian or Pakistani heritage
she cannot be held wholly or directly
responsible for the criminal behavior of
others who used her allegations as an
excuse for their own inexcusable conduct
but it was foreseeable that others would
behave in anti-social and unacceptable
ways
it was not foreseeable that her cause
would be taken up by those outside
Barrow and developed the extent that it
did however some Community impact was
foreseeable to that limited extent I
take into account the community impact
the harm of this offending extends to an
undermining of public confidence in the
criminal justice system
we are aware that sex trafficking of
young females does occur
there is a risk that genuine victims
will as a result of this defendant's
actions feel deterred from reporting it
people may be less likely to believe
their allegations I'm sure that those
charged with investigating such offenses
will do all in their power to avoid any
reluctance to investigate such
allegations
in this case I make reduction for the
defendant's age
then for personal mitigation in relation
to count 9 only I reduce the sentence
for credit for a guilty plea I then
further adjust the sentences for
totality
to assist in understanding how I've
arrived at my overall sentence I first
set out the sentences after after trial
for each count without applying any
reduction for any of these factors
in relation to count one the sentence
would have been two years imprisonment
for counts two three and four five years
imprisonment concurrent with each other
but consecutive to the sentence on count
one
for counts five six and seven seven and
a half years imprisonment concurrent
with each other but consecutive of the
sentences already imposed for count
eight two years imprisonment and for
count nine one year and four months
imprisonment both consecutive to the
sentence is already imposed
I then turn to the various reductions
for the factors mentioned above
the defendant was a child when she
committed the offense at count one the
relevant guideline indicates that the
court should take as its starting point
the sentence likely to have been imposed
on the date at which the offense was
committed that sentence would have been
if custodial detention and training
order of less than two years the
reduction from the adult sentence will
be one half for count one
in relation to the other counts the
reduction for age will be of the order
of one quarter
though based on there will be a
reduction for age of one-third from the
adult sentence in relation to count two
to four
in relation to the other counts the
reduction for age will be of the order
of one quarter she was 19 during much of
this offending
after her false allegations about Mr
trengov this was not impulsive offending
arising from naivety that explains the
Lesser reduction
I then reduced the sentences further to
take account of her personal mitigation
I then reduced a sentence on count nine
to reflect her credit
finally I take account of totality I do
this by making the sentences on counts
eight and nine concurrent with each
other and other sentences and by further
reducing the sentences on counts five to
seven
Eleanor Williams please stand up
these are the sentences that you will
serve on count one there will be a
sentence of six months imprisonment
on counts three to five the sentence
will be three years imprisonment
concurrent on each count but consecutive
to the sentence on count one giving a
total so far of three and a half years
there will be sentences of Five Years on
counts five six and seven concurrent
with one another but consecutive to the
sentences already imposed
finally there will be a sentence of one
year and three months imprisonment on
count eight and six months imprisonment
on count nine those sentences to run
concurrently with each other and the
other sentences imposed that gives a
total sentence of eight and a half years
imprisonment
you will serve half of the total
sentence of imprisonment in custody
after which you will be released on
license
the days spent in custody will count
towards your sentence
you've spent 361 days on a qualifying
curfew because of that the time you must
spend in custody is reduced by 179 days
if that figure is incorrect it can be
corrected later without a further
hearing
on release your license will be subject
to conditions
if you breach the terms of your license
you'll be liable to be recalled to serve
the remainder of the sentence
there is an application for a serious
crime prevention order I find that this
is a serious offense for the purposes of
this application there are reasonable
grounds for believing that the order
will protect the public I exercise my
discretion in favor of making the order
as sought with amendments to the effect
that she may also possess a tablet and
games console and you may also be able
to operate a work and a personal email
that order will run for a period of five
years from the 17th of February 2025
I order deprivation and destruction of
the items on page one of divider eight
of the Crown's bundle of documents
if the statutory surcharge applies the
order can be drawn up in the appropriate
amount
thank you sit down please
that was Judge Robert alterman pressing
Crown Court passing a sentence of eight
and a half years on Eleanor Williams who
was found guilty of perverting the
course of Justice over false gang
grooming allegations apologies again to
our viewers for anything they may have
heard during the sentencing remarks
which might have caused uh distress
let's bring in Jason Farrell our home
Affairs Editor to to react to this uh
Jason during that the judge saying that
he was sure her entire claims were false
and she knew that she were that they
were false in making them and passed a
sentence of eight and a half years in
present prison and additional uh one
year nine months that can be served
concurrently within that but eight and a
half year sentence of which at least
half will be served in prison
yeah I think anyone who just listen
through to that summing up by the judge
there as he went into the sentencing
will if they're hearing it for the first
time realize that this is one of the
most extraordinary cases that has ever
been heard in this court this is the
woman who lied and kicked up a storm in
her hometown of Barrow Eleanor Williams
when she posted that Facebook post in
May 2020 it was locked down a lot of
people were at home and it was read by
tens of thousands of people and it led
to protest it led to people being spat
at in the street their businesses had
bricks thrown through their windows I
spoke to some Indian restaurant owners
who say that they lost a large
proportion of their businesses some had
to take out loans because people stopped
going there the local newspaper came
under scrutiny because they were
reporting the fact that she was being
investigated for perverting the course
of justice and what the police couldn't
say at that time was that they had
strong evidence that Eleanor Williams
was lying that everything she was saying
about being raped was a fabrication and
the pictures that she'd posted online of
herself beaten black and blue they were
shocking photographs that they those
injuries had been caused by herself
self-inflicted with a hammer that she
had purchased at Tesco just a few days
earlier and that they had DNA evidence
to suggest that those were all
self-inflicted and indeed other injuries
that she'd been seen to have at other
times they also suggest were
self-inflicted I've sat in on this case
which ran up to Christmas last year and
it has been an extraordinary set of
evidence with young women coming forward
for example having to say that they
weren't at sex parties that Eleanor
Williams said that they were at men who
had been accused of rape taking the
stand to say that they had uh you know
they had nothing to do with Eleanor
Williams one man who hardly knew her who
was accused of being at the heart of a
trafficking ring trafficking her to
Amsterdam I'm to Ibiza all of which were
claims that were proven to be untrue in
the end so this really is the
culmination of a lot of pain for those
particular men and I think now we can
hear uh from is it the judge talking
about Eleanor Williams's whether she's
shown any remorse here's what he had to
say
it is troubling to say the least that
she shows no significant sign of remorse
even continuing to profess the truth of
her allegations
the only flicker of appreciation of what
she has done came today with a brief
note read by Her counsel regretting the
effects of her post on the 20th of May
2020.
well all we heard was that statement
from Eleanor Williams in which she said
I know I've made some mistakes and I'm
sorry I was young and Confused I'm not
saying I'm guilty but I know I've done
some wrong and I'm so sorry I spoke to
some of the men that she'd accused after
hearing that statement and they felt
that that was a hollow apology they
didn't feel that it had any meaning at
all and indeed the judge said he felt
that Eleanor Williams had shown no sign
of remorse he did say it is troubling
that we really don't know why she made
up all of these lies
Jason Farrell thanks so much for that
outside Preston at Crown Court